buenos días los peruanos se sienten
indignados con este escándalo y le piden
a su gobierno que dé a conocer la lista
completa con nombres y apellidos de los
funcionarios y sus allegados quienes
irregularmente fueron vacunados con la
inoculación de signo farc todos ellos
van a ser investigados y posteriormente
sancionados pero el escándalo tiene
mayores ribetes de atención en lo
referente al expresidente martín
vizcarra la fiscalía le ha abierto un
proceso y va a ser investigado por los
delitos contra la administración pública
concusión con negociación incompatible o
aprovechamiento indebido culpable por
esto si el exgobernante es hallado
culpable puede afrontar una condena de
cinco a ocho años de prisión
francisco algunos argumentan como el ex
presidente martín vizcarra que fueron
voluntarios de los ensayos que estaban
haciendo en perú la farmacéutica china
que ha desarrollado la vacuna conocida
como scinopharm que dicen entonces las
autoridades y la universidad que estaba
a cargo precisamente de este proceso de
investigación y cómo es que no se dio
cuenta que vacunó a 487 funcionarios del
gobierno de manera anticipada
ni la universidad peruana cayetano
heredia ni el jefe de los ensayos sin
clínicos el doctor germán málaga han
dado a conocer los detalles se espera
que todo esto sea esclarecido en las
próximas horas ante la fiscalía y el
congreso de perú entidades que llevan
procesos de investigación por separado
pero las cosas van más allá de la
situación en respecto nuevamente al ex
presidente de martín vizcarra porque no
solamente al fue vacunado también su
esposa y su hermano mayor y por si esto
no fuera poco el exmandatario figura en
una lista de bomberos de la región
moquegua ubicada al sur del perú donde
él fue gobernador pues bien en esa lista
figura martín vizcarra como bombero
voluntario y la nómina señala que debe
ser vacunado por ser personal que
pertenece a la primera línea en el
combate contra el coronavirus gracias a
francisco por este reporte desde la
ciudad de lima y atentos a lo que se
vaya desarrollando a lo largo del día